El éxito de nuestro algoritmo VQE depende
en gran medida del estado y el circuit
con los que elijamos comenzar.
Soy Victoria Lipinska y en este video
exploraremos las opciones
que tenemos para diseñarlos.
Veamos más de cerca
todos los elementos
que tenemos en cada ejecución de la parte
cuántica del VQE.
Comenzamos con el estado de referencia,
a veces llamado estado inicial.
Pasamos el estado de referencia
por un circuit parametrizado llamado
forma variacional
con una elección inicial de parámetros,
y medimos el estado
en la base del Hamiltoniano
después de pasarlo por el circuit
para obtener el valor esperado. Ahora
recorreremos cada uno de estos elementos,
comenzando con el estado de referencia.
Una elección típica para el estado
de referencia es el estado cero.
Es decir, el estado en el que una computadora
cuántica ya está inicializada.
Para problemas de química cuántica,
también se puede usar el llamado
estado de Hartree-Fock,
que es el resultado del método
de Hartree-Fock.
En resumen, la teoría de Hartree-Fock
ofrece una forma sencilla de construir
el estado de referencia aproximando
el estado fundamental de un sistema cuántico.
Encuentra una rotación
dentro del espacio de estados
que minimiza la energía del estado fundamental.
Por último, el estado de referencia
también puede ser muy específico del problema,
y puede que quieras elegir
un estado personalizado.
En el caso de que sepas qué propiedades
tiene tu sistema, por ejemplo, simetrías
o un número específico de electrones
en el estado, puedes usar eso
para lograr una mejor convergencia
del algoritmo VQE.
Elegir un buen estado de referencia
es importante para la convergencia;
estados de referencia que estén cerca
del estado fundamental
pueden hacer que el problema converja
mucho más fácil y rápido.
Igualmente importante
es la elección de los valores iniciales de los parámetros
que introducimos en la forma variacional.
Por lo tanto, dependiendo del estado
de referencia y los parámetros iniciales,
podemos converger rápidamente, lentamente
o no converger en absoluto.
Veamos este gráfico
y con fines de visualización,
imaginemos que nuestro espacio de parámetros
tiene solo un parámetro.
Un muy buen estado de referencia
puede permitirte empezar muy cerca
del estado fundamental final
y entonces la convergencia será rápida.
Por otro lado, si empiezas muy lejos
del estado fundamental aquí,
estado de referencia
a, tendrás que cruzar una barrera de alta energía
lo que lleva a una convergencia muy lenta
o a no converger en absoluto.
Discutiremos esto con más profundidad
en el módulo de optimización clásica
de este curso.
Veamos ahora el circuit parametrizado
que actúa sobre el estado de referencia,
la forma variacional.
Cuando este circuit, el conocido
U de theta, actúa sobre el estado
de referencia,
produce lo que llamamos un estado de prueba
psi de theta o a veces ansatz.
Es este estado ansatz el que luego
se mide en una base apropiada
para obtener el valor esperado
de la energía.
Las formas variacionales
que discutimos aquí
están motivadas por la química.
Sin embargo, ten en cuenta
que también existen aquellas inspiradas
por el aprendizaje automático cuántico
y otros algoritmos
de corto plazo como los algoritmos
de optimización aproximada cuántica.
Discutamos algunas opciones comunes
para un ansatz de química.
El clúster acoplado unitario o UCC
es el método propuesto originalmente
en la primera publicación de VQE,
y se usa comúnmente en problemas
de química cuántica.
Típicamente,
cuando parametrizamos un estado cuántico,
trabajamos con exponencialmente
muchos parámetros.
Sin embargo, para hacer que los circuits
de preparación sean eficientes,
necesitamos un número polinomial
de operaciones
y por lo tanto un número polinomial
de parámetros.
UCC es un ejemplo de una forma de preparar
un estado de prueba con dicho circuit
y se deriva del método de clúster
acoplado,
que es el estándar de oro en la química
cuántica.
La opción más común es el clúster
acoplado unitario
de simples y dobles,
ansatz o UCCSD en forma abreviada.
Debido a que UCCSD está motivado por la
configuración electrónica específica de un problema,
necesitamos asegurarnos de tener un estado
de referencia que refleje adecuadamente el sistema.
Este es el estado de Hartree-Fock.
El ansatz UCCSD generalmente da
una buena aproximación del estado fundamental
porque captura excitaciones electrónicas
simples y dobles en una molécula dada.
El número de parámetros en UCCSD escala
cuadráticamente con el número de orbitales
de espín.
UCCSD puede adaptarse muy bien
a un problema,
pero desafortunadamente, el escalamiento
cuadrático aún lleva a circuits muy profundos
que son difíciles para las computadoras
cuánticas actuales.
Por eso los investigadores de IBM propusieron
un enfoque más heurístico,
donde se puede adaptar una forma variacional
al hardware subyacente
lo que resulta en un circuit
ejecutable de manera eficiente.
Es decir, los estados de prueba se parametrizan
mediante gates cuánticos
y se adaptan al dispositivo
físico disponible.
Este es un enfoque muy heurístico
que es amigable con el hardware.
Con base en estos ejemplos, veamos
el espectro de posibilidades
que tenemos para expresar
nuestra forma variacional.
Muchas de estas ya están
implementadas en Qiskit
así que te animo a que pruebes por ti mismo
cuál es la más adecuada
para el problema que intentas resolver.
Si miramos el gráfico, por un lado
tenemos las formas variacionales
muy heurísticas.
Cuando la especificidad del problema es baja, pero
están diseñadas para implementarse
en hardware real.
También son altamente expresivas,
en el sentido
de que se pueden expresar
muchos estados cuánticos con ellas.
Sin embargo,
un problema que puede ocurrir en la etapa
posterior de la optimización clásica
es encontrar
la llamada meseta estéril,
que discutiremos en el siguiente módulo.
Por otro lado,
tenemos el clúster acoplado unitario
altamente específico del problema, que funciona
excelente en la química clásica pero
es difícil de implementar en el hardware
cuántico debido a las grandes profundidades de circuit.
En general, los cálculos
pueden ser más exitosos si puedes,
primero, elegir un estado de referencia
y un conjunto inicial de parámetros
que creen un estado ansatz
cercano al estado fundamental.
Y segundo, evitar parámetros innecesarios.
Estos o introducen
mayor profundidad de circuit sin beneficio
o crean un espacio de parámetros más grande
para buscar, lo que lleva a mesetas
en la optimización clásica.
Qué parámetros son necesarios es una pregunta
específica del problema
que requiere una reflexión cuidadosa.
Hablemos de dónde se esconde nuestro invitado de honor,
el Hamiltoniano, en todo esto.
Como aprendimos en la sección anterior,
el Hamiltoniano después del mapeo
de qubits se representa como una suma de
cadenas ponderadas de operadores de Pauli.
Sin embargo, eventualmente
queremos evaluar el valor esperado
de nuestro Hamiltoniano sobre el estado
ansatz producido por la forma variacional.
Afortunadamente, la mecánica cuántica
es agradable y lineal
y esto es lo que usaremos
para obtener el valor esperado.
Así es como funciona.
Sabemos que el Hamiltoniano es una suma
ponderada de Paulis.
Debido a la linealidad,
el valor esperado de la suma
es igual a la suma de los valores esperados
de cada cadena de Pauli.
Bueno, esto es genial porque como ya
sabes, medir en la base de Pauli
es tan simple como una rotación
de la base de medición estándar.
En lugar de medir el valor esperado
sobre este enorme Hamiltoniano representado
como una suma, primero evaluamos los valores
esperados de los términos individuales
y sumamos al final
con los pesos correspondientes.
Por eso en muchos recursos
verás solo rotaciones de un solo qubit
después del ansatz.
Esto es lo que implementa el Hamiltoniano
en cada ejecución del circuit.
En el siguiente video,
exploraremos lo que sucede
durante el paso de optimización clásica.
Nos vemos allí.